Now, you really can't reverse trisomy
21, which is the technical name for Down
syndrome.
But, the effects on appearance and
behavior,
I guess it's a day and night difference
over the first 6 months on the Plant
Derived Minerals, to the point where the
doctor is just totally baffled. But, to
hear stories like that, to hear stories
about kidney function, to hear stories
about uh changing uh losing memory or
long-term memory challenges, losing uh
hearing stories about kids having torn
ACLs and being able to get back on the
the plane, turf, or field, or court in
months instead of a year, is
makes me feel so much better as a human
being.
Um do I like receiving my paycheck? Yes.
But, do I feel better hearing the
stories?
That's a true statement. If I didn't
make money, I'd still make the product
and making sure that it I could get it
in front of as many people as I can,
just because it's my way of giving back
to society.